very good morning to you people in their
late 40s are expected to be next in line
to book their covid vaccine after the
announcement of the next phase of jabs
will begin
in the coming days all over 50s in
england
have now been offered a vaccine so it's
expected people in their late 40s
will be next in line to start being
inoculated with invitations starting in
the coming days
the nhs has confirmed 95 of people
in the nine most vulnerable groups have
now been vaccinated that's ahead of
target
the moderna vaccine rollout starts in
england today
the uk has ordered 17 million doses
that's enough for
eight and a half million people it comes
as the largest
surge testing operation so far takes
place in parts of south london
after more than 70 confirmed or probable
cases of the south african variant of
covid19 were detected
there's fantastic news that we're going
to have met the target to vaccinate
groups one to nine
that means that the highest risk
population in the in the country
are vaccinated and will have protection
from severe disease and hospitalization
we've got a long way to go
the next group coming forward group 10
their 40 to 50 year olds
really need to step forward and take the
vaccination when they're offered
well celebrations for the easing of
lockdown restrictions went on
well into the night in towns and cities
across england with
people making the most of their newfound
freedoms but there is a warning this
morning from nhs leaders
not to become complacent elena
veselnovich reports
they danced well into the night the joy
of emerging from lockdown palpable
filling out streets and squares all day
people pack tables across the country
relishing the newly restored sense of
normality
it's so fabulous so exciting
after a year of being locked in oh it
feels great
yeah it's amazing there's nothing like
it are you concerned it's all about
purge
um yes to a certain extent i am
obviously but if you're taking the
necessary precautions you should be fine
from stockton and teas you want to let
your hair down
so even though i've had a haircut this
morning i'm ready for the finds and the
shots and the food so
to oxford
and london venues stage yet another
reopening of this pandemic
each previous one ending in shutdowns
we start something off we get into a
momentum and then we stop again
it's the stop start issue um but
it needed to be done but we felt like
we've been restarting a couple of times
and
we have no sense of momentum there but
yet again
customers flocked back despite the
chilly weather
there's a real party atmosphere here and
optimism that things are finally
back on track and everyone here hopes
that after
three long lockdowns these hard-won
freedoms
are here to stay the pm has urged the
nation to be cautious
as the largest search testing operation
to date is underway in south london
because of cases of the south african
variant scientists warn
we still need to be careful we've all
sacrificed so much over the last few
months and it is a joyous day it's
it's it's a step and an important step
on the
on the on the road map to to freedom so
i think it's a joyous day
but also a day where perhaps we also
need to operate with some degree of
caution
on the streets the party was in full
swing late into the night
amid hope that this important step on
the road to reopening
will be irreversible milena vassilinovic
sky news well the largest surge testing
operation to date is taking place today
in parts of south london where a cluster
of cases of the south african variant
have been found well let's head over to
our reporter becky cottrell and just how
big an operation is this going to be
becky
well as you say it's the largest surge
testing operation to have been
undertaken in the country
what they're advising is anyone over the
age of 11 who lives in
works in or travels through these two
boroughs lamberth
and wandsworth in south london to come
forward and get a pcr test
you can actually pick up one from 8 am
from lambeth town hall behind me
as well as other locations across the
area those in-person pickups are for
people with no symptoms
if you have symptoms you should order
one online and take it at home
it needs to be a pcr test because those
tests can then be sent off to a
specialist lab
undergo genomic sequencing to look for
variants of concern
like the south african variant to see
just how widely spread it might be here
so concerning news there but good news
for the vaccine rollout those
top nine cohorts have undergone have
been offered
their vaccine and now we expect the
under 50s to get their letters to come
forward
in the coming days we expect it to
precede the vaccine roller as it has
done already
oldest to youngest and the government
are hoping to vaccinate
all adults by the end of july okay becky
thank you well let's have a look at the
latest covid figures for you
and 3568 new coved 19 cases have been
recorded
along with 13 more deaths across the uk
that takes a total number of people
who've died within 28 days of a positive
test
to 127 100.
more than 32 million first doses of a
vaccine have been given
the number of people getting a second
dose is now
over 7.6 million
well let's talk to professor of
pediatrics at the university of bristol
uh adam finn i know you're clearly a
member of the the joint committee on
vaccination and immunisation as well
which is crucial
as we talk look can we talk about the
vaccination figures
uh at this stage because we are ahead of
target
how important is that milestone
i think it's an enormously significant
milestone stephen because
this really represents the culmination
of phase one which was
really aimed at trying to rescue the nhs
from the enormous surge
of cases that we had at the beginning of
the year of course the lockdown has
contributed very significantly to that
success as well
um but it's uh we're halfway up the hill
if you like
we can look back and be pleased with
what we've achieved but we need to look
forward
uh to uh get to the summit and uh really
finish this off
i mean part of the the success story we
know when we look at the figures has
been the
the take-up of the vaccine which has
been extraordinarily high for both first
and
and second doses is there concern that
that
may drop off the younger the demographic
is that's being targeted
well i think we've certainly got an
important job to do to communicate the
importance of
uh of the vaccination program to younger
people
they perhaps have less fear of this
disease
than older people quite understandably
have had uh but nevertheless
uh i i think people can be helped to
understand that the ultimate
exit from this catastrophe involves
building up immunity in the population
what what's happened up until now is
that we've
had this virus everywhere in our
population because no one
initially had any immunity at all we
need to get to a point where
so many people are immune to it that
there's the virus is left with nowhere
to go
and that means that younger people do
need to come forward in large numbers as
older people have done
in order to achieve that goal but as
we've got this surge testing underway in
london at the moment what sort of
problems
are going to be caused by new variants
coming in even if we are vaccinated or
the majority of us
are vaccinated a new potentially
dangerous variant still going to cause
us a problem
uh well that is obviously a concern i
think the evidence we've got so far
suggests that these vaccines do have
activity and protection
against the other virus variants that
have emerged around the world
but we are going to probably have to
modify the vaccines to keep
up with that viral evolution as time
goes by
nevertheless the more people who receive
vaccines for now
the better control we'll have over the
viruses that are circulating
and will also be able to [ __ ] the
speed with which the virus can evolve
and escape
so it's it's really a bit of a race
against the virus
the faster we can get more people immune
the less of a problem these variants
will be
um how how big a step is it that modern
is coming on stream in england
today to get together another vaccine
available to people
well really useful to have yet another
tool in the toolbox
and there are more tools to come so a
really important
next step we've been told that the
government has
contracted with a number of different
manufacturers for vaccines
and to see a third one come through to
add to the two we have already
is certainly very reassuring um and
i think another step along the way
towards a comprehensive program that can
really protect us all
how difficult is it moving forward for
us now because obviously we're giving
ourselves a pat on the back for the
vaccine program and
understandably so but there is now this
great concern when you look at countries
like chile that's had this
this hugely successful vaccine rollout
but he's now seeing a
a big spike in cases now clearly we
we've got a
a different environment a different
demographic to chile
but are there lessons that we can learn
from what's happening there
right i think we do need to understand
exactly what's going on in chile
it may relate to the the vaccines used
there
and the viruses circulating there but i
think the message for us
is that we can't now relax and assume
that
the problem is is finished we need to
continue
to be vigilant we need to use all the
tools not just vaccines
there are now new tests available to
people they can test themselves
to be vigilant for the virus and even
though we've been
told that we can relax in our cautions
around
contacting each other we should continue
to be really careful
to avoid the spread of infection we
should use masks we should use hand
hygiene
and we should avoid close contact with
other people particularly indoors
because otherwise we will see a return
of cases and potentially
hospitalizations as well
okay professor finn good to talk to you
this morning thank you
i just want to bring you some breaking
economic news for you this morning let's
head straight to our business
correspondent helen
smith who's in the newsroom what have
you got helen ann
morning so we've had figures uh this
morning for gdp
gross domestic product uh it's the total
value of all products and services in
the economy
the best barometer we have really to
take the temperature of how the economy
uh is doing we have trade figures as
well which i'll take you through uh in a
minute but gdp first
the figures for february show that the
economy actually recovered
uh a smidge in the month of february
grew by 0.4
uh actually some relatively good news
given the fact that vast swathes of the
economy were still
completely shut in the month to february
and we've seen
lots of months haven't we with big
dramatic falls over the last year during
the crisis
it might reflect a few things uh the
rollout of the vaccine businesses
getting used to operating under lockdown
the fact that the furlough speak scheme
has been continued and that all
adds to confidence so a small recovery
there worth of course saying though that
we're still down
7.8 on what it was in february last year
and still significantly below
the sort of post-crisis recovery peak
which was seen
in october so some way to go but a
smidge of encouraging news
there but all eyes as well this morning
will have been on the trade figures
they're also released by the office for
national statistics now these really
mattered this month
because it's the the month of february
that we're seeing it is the second month
of figures we've seen
since the brexit trade deal came into
force and last month
in january the first month under that
new deal
figures for imports and exports to the
eu fell off dramatically
record falls uh on what um we've seen
since these records began
a slight recovery today and i think
there'll be sighs of relief
within the government and elsewhere
exports uh recovered by
um sorry beg your pardon exports
it recovered increased by 3.7 billion
pounds that's an increase of 46.6 they'd
fallen by 5.7 billion in january so
a decent recovery certainly not back to
what they were
pre the brexit trade deal coming into
force but i suspect there'll be a little
relief from government for sure
okay hello dan thank you now still to
come
this morning we're going to be reporting
from india where a huge
festival based by the river ganges has
attracted millions of people
in a country facing an upsurge in covet
cases
also our seven-year-old henry has
inspired other children to provide
for those in poverty and at 8 40 i'll be
talking to tv presenter laura hamilton
about the average price of a house
reaching a record high since the start
of the pandemic
now demonstrators have clashed with
police in minnesota for a second night
after a 20 year old black man was shot
by a police officer
sally lockwood reports on the protest
where tear gas
and rubber bullets were used
for a second night people clashed with
police
after the death of another black man by
another of their officers
peaceful protest turn to looting and
violence
but an already tense time for this city
body cam footage showing the
unfathomable events unfold
a routine traffic stop ending in death
an officer shooting a 20 year old black
man they say
by mistake she intended to use her taser
father of one dante wright died after
being shot
by a single bullet
[Music]
his family attended a vigil ahead of
another curfew order
dante's mother addressing the crowd
my heart is literally broken into a
thousand pieces
and i don't know what to do or what to
say
but i just need everybody to know that
he is much
more than this the sight of george
floyd's family lawyer here
perhaps said it all mr crown your
reaction to the death of dante wright
unnecessary just so unnecessary
this young man never should have been
killed by the police
that's why we have to get the george
floyd justice and police and
accountability at
pass just 10 miles away former officer
derek shovin
is on trial for the murder of george
floyd his younger brother
giving emotional evidence as the family
sat through more tough testimony had he
not
been restrained in the way in which he
was
i think he would have survived that day
amid anxiety over the outcome of this
trial
they're already calling for justice for
another will you'll be back tomorrow
night yes ma'am of course i'm gonna be
out here every day i'm gonna be out here
until they give us some justice
until they make a change i'm gonna be
out here
[Music]
a familiar war of fireworks tear gas
and rubber bullets for many here this is
a story
they've seen before same story just a
different name and a story that doesn't
feel
like it has an ending
but it feels like the start of another
unsettling chapter for this city
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis
where you can see continuous coverage of
the derrick chauvin trial streaming live
on our website
and app on youtube and on a special
pop-up channel you can find on sky524
more than 100 mps gave eulogies to the
duke of edinburgh alongside
the parliaments of london edinburgh and
cardiff yesterday
prince william and prince harry
separately paid tribute to prince philip
with william describing his
grandfather's life as one
defined by service
well you can watch full coverage of
prince philip's funeral
here on sky news this saturday at two
o'clock
island has announced that the
astrazeneca vaccine will only be given
to those people aged 60 and over
concerns over rare blood clots has
caused many european countries to limit
their use of the vaccine
the irish government is in the process
of completing the rollout amongst those
over 70
and plans to move to the over 65s later
this month
new research into the coronavirus
variant first detected in kent and now
dominant in the uk
has found it's more transmissible but
doesn't increase the severity of the
illness
two studies found no evidence that
people with a variant have worse
symptoms
or are more likely to develop long covid
a student who shot at police officers in
tennessee high school has been killed
authorities say the knoxville student
was found in a bathroom and when ordered
to leave opened fire
the people died at the school after
being shot by police an officer was
injured
after being hit in the leg
the government will face new pressure to
reveal more about david cameron's
lobbying activities today when it faces
questions from
labour over the collapsed financial firm
greens hill capital
ali fortescue is here for us this
morning i mean this is not going away
labour seems determined to keep the
pressure on
that's right the saga continues and
labour are forcing an urgent question in
the comments today they wanted to see
rishi sunak the chancel answering
those questions instead it is going to
be a junior business minister but
they've made very clear as you say
they're not going to let up
pressure they are not happy with the
independent
inquiry that the government said was
being announced yesterday they want more
scrutiny for those ministers like
rishi sunak and matt hancock that had
been lobbied by the former prime
minister
david cameron rishi sunak of course we
saw those texts
earlier this week about the covid loans
scheme the health secretary
who he'd had a drink with about an app
that was later rolled out
in the nhs it is worth reminding people
that
um david cameron has already been
cleared by the lobbying
watchdog he has always said that he
hasn't done anything wrong he didn't
break the rules but admits
that it doesn't look good and i think
you know there's a real irony of course
that david cameron is someone who went
out of his way to say
that lobbying was the next big scandal
to happen here he is
right at the center of this scandal but
i think this is going to become about
much more than just
cameron and green still but it's really
going to focus
minds on the murky world of lobbying
more broadly i think
okay ali thank you now japan's
government has started
releasing massive amounts of treated
radioactive water from the wrecked
fukushima nuclear plant
the controversial move is facing
opposition from those living close
to the site well let's talk
to tom cheshire who's standing by for us
this morning hopefully somewhere
anyway tom hopefully can he hopefully
can hear us
and tell them i mean clearly this is a
controversial move but we're told up
with that this
this water this wastewater is now
absolutely safe
it's not absolutely safe it does meet
some of the minimum
thresholds just to say this hasn't
started yet it's supposed to start in a
couple of years it'll take decades to do
and this is a solution that is causing a
lot of
disapproval from people in the region
but the problem is a really big one
there's a huge amount of
radioactive water on site both that was
used to cool
fukushimi a nuclear plant before it's
multiple meltdowns and also groundwater
rainwater that's been seeping in since
then
it's about 1.25 million tons 500
500 olympic sized swimming pools of
contaminated water
and it costs around a billion dollars to
store every year so solution
being proposed by japan is that they let
it out into the ocean
taking out as much of the radioactive
elements as they can apart from tritium
which is one radioactive element it's
very hard to separate
that will be in there but they say
they'll dilute it and therefore it will
be
safe to release into the ocean other
countries in the region japan's
neighbors are very concerned about this
taiwan south korea saying they don't
want this water release
china has called it extremely
irresponsible and says that japan is not
looking
after um looking after environmental
protections as much as
it should be now this hasn't happened
yet it still has two years before it
happens but it's already
a huge source of contention within the
region as we get close to that date when
it actually releases this water it dumps
it
into the sea i think it's going to be a
lot more friction here in east asia
okay tom thank you well just a reminder
you can keep up with stories like this
on the daily climate show here on sky
news every weekday
at half six and half nine
now how about this for a hair-raising
tale
he's said to be the biggest rabbit in
the world
but he's been stolen from his home in
worcestershire police believe darius a
flemish giant was taken from his
enclosure in stolten on saturday night
the owner has offered a thousand pound
reward for darius who's recognized by
the guinness world records
as being the longest living rabbit
measuring 129 centimeters
from nose to tail
why would you steal a rabbit crazy
let's have a look at the weather for you
now here's joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well the
weather's looking really quite quiet for
the middle of the week
high pressure in control and so we're
not really looking at any surprises
however we will still see uh some rather
cold nights and uh widespread frost no
more sudden this morning when we've got
minus four minus five over parts of the
country but also some lovely sunshine to
go with that
now there is a little more cloud over
parts of ireland wales
the southwest parts of northern england
too few isolated showers around those
showers will become more widespread
through the course
of the day but we're not looking at
masses and if you do catch one well it
will be quite
sharp or might be quite sharp with the
orbit of hail mixed in
but we've lost the winter-ness which is
good news and temperatures quite
generally into double figures 11 to 13
degrees celsius locally we could find
14 that's 57 degrees fahrenheit so those
showers extend a little further
eastwards through the day then
into the evening they start to die away
once more and the cloud will melt as
well which means if you're looking at
sitting outside this evening
best take a jump or a coat with you
because temperatures will drop quite
rapidly
once night falls so again we're looking
at a widespread frost for wednesday
morning some mist and fog around as well
and then very much a rerun of today
we're looking at a few showers
developing
again the focus will be on these western
areas eastern parts of ireland
and temperatures again it's double
figures a high of around 14 celsius
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
joe thank you still to come on sky news
breakfast as india
is experiencing its worst pandemic surge
will talk to a health expert about the
situation in the country
and how it compares to others
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're coming firing diggers
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded
five nuclear warheads
[Music]
this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
shrapnel from that explosion you can see
it littered along
all the way we take you to the heart of
the stories that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports
that they are being blocked by police so
we're going to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance
we help you understand the world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now india's kamela festival is attended
by
tens of millions of people and this year
in spite of the pandemic
it's no different hindus and right
across the region have begun their
pilgrimage to celebrate along the river
ganges
now with a total of over three and a
half 13 and a half million cases of eggy
pardon
india has overtaken brazil to become the
second
most affected country globally by
coronavirus
only the united states has a higher
number of cases
with 31.2 million now despite more than
three million people a day
getting coveted vaccines that equates to
less than six percent of the country
sparking worries that large gatherings
like the kumela festival
could exacerbate the situation the
festival is one of the main events in
the hindu calendar but comes at a time
where india is experiencing its worst
surge in new infections since the
pandemic began
seeing more than 130 000 new cases every
day
this year the festival is taking place
in the northern city
of haridwar from where neville lazarus
reports
a congregation of millions for this once
in 12-year hindu festival of the
mahakuma
devotees have descended from all parts
of the country on the banks of the river
ganga
for a holy tip all this
amidst a raging pandemic
india now records the highest number of
daily cases in the world
and is second only to the united states
with over 13.5 million cases
the festival allowed by the hindu
nationalist party
of prime minister modi has come under
severe criticism
millions of pilgrims from all corners of
the country are here
health experts have flagged this as a
super spreader as it's impossible
to implement any kovich restrictions in
this large crowd
the reality is that the administration
is struggling
[Applause]
there is a rush to reach the main banks
before the auspicious time
passes the police are overwhelmed
saraswati and her husband have traveled
hundreds of miles from rajasthan
for many weeks the country has been
immersed in state elections
the prime minister his cabinet and
leaders of all political parties
are campaigning at rallies with
thousands in attendance
roadshows by politicians expose every
nook
and corner vaccination process
started slow but has picked up base
there is a long way to go as less than
one percent of the population
have completed their full dose
events like these could be avoided at a
time when the country is in the grip
of a deadly second wave
the rising numbers do not bode well for
a nation
which has poor public health facilities
and services
never lazarus sky news haridwar
well let's talk to professor and head of
life course epidemiology at the public
health foundation of india
doctor giroud along with global health
expert at oxford university
dr peter drobach who we talked to about
the situation
in chile good to see you both this
morning dr babu
clearly the situation in india is is
hugely concerning with these
absolutely massive crowds gathering why
do you think the message is not
resonating in india
yeah i think there are more problems
than what
india could anticipate now once the
cases
were absolutely at its lowest during
december and almost the
end of january there was a feeling of
maybe we have
won over the virus and therefore
the elections were announced and also
this
kum mela that you are showing is a very
cultural and religious belief and if you
could listen to one of the
participants at the mela mrs saraswati
she said
anyway i have to die i might as well
come to the mela and then
see god god will take care so this kind
of cultural belief is very difficult to
shake and you could not probably prevent
a mela like this but
currently what happens in terms of the
kovid 19 response in india
will hold key for how well the entire
world
veeams over this battle mostly because
higher the circulation more might be the
new variants developing
uh second i either in terms of
controlling mortality especially in the
states with the poor health system
response
it's going to be a challenge i think we
need to regroup
and reprioritize uh in terms of lowering
the mortality
uh because the numbers that we are
seeing are much larger and at a much
faster pace compared to the first wave
scheme yeah i was going to
say what sort of mortality rate are you
looking at
and what sort of condition are the the
health services in
across india especially the the the icu
the intensive care
department so they completely
overwhelmed now
yeah so uh based on our experience in
the first wave
because of the nationwide lockdown many
states
at the entire country level have stepped
up their response in
having more ventilators ensuring that
there are more oxygenated beds
so therefore many states are able to
cope up with the surge in cases
to a greater extent however there are
some states where
traditionally there is poor health
system infrastructure
currently the mortality rate is not
really high
in the second wave but this might change
very soon because once there is a
surge and then there is not enough you
know infrastructure to cater to the
surging cases especially the severe
cases then the modality can
go high but so far most of nearly 90
of the infections are asymptomatic and
most people who are
infected are in the young age groups
therefore we are okay
so far in terms of mortality but we have
to contain it right now
to have this advantage as we move
forward okay so that's the situation in
india let's turn our attention to chile
which
is causing a lot of concern actually dr
drobach why are we seeing this situation
in chile which has had
a hugely successful vaccination program
as far as we understand it
and now seeing a huge surge in cases
what's going on
thanks for having me this is a really
important cautionary tale i think
as we move forward with our vaccination
campaign so so chile as you mentioned
has been considered a real
coveted vaccination success story in
population adjusted terms is about third
in the world behind
israel in the uae actually a little bit
ahead of the uk about 40 percent of
chileans have received one dose and 25
two dose of the vaccine at the same time
they're currently experiencing a surge
that is the worst surge of cover they've
experienced throughout this pandemic
and in fact recently went into a hard
lockdown
and what's happened was as the
vaccination rollout was even progressing
fairly quickly
they really let down their guard and so
social distancing restrictions were
relaxed
very early on the summer holidays back
in january were allowed to happen and
border restrictions were eased
and in general i think there was a lot
more travel within the country and
mixing
and so what happened was infections
began to rise well before any kind of
protective effect of having a portion of
the population vaccinated happened
and they're now paying the price for
that i think it's a reminder for all of
us that vaccines are so important
but they alone won't be enough for us to
end this pandemic that
vaccines need to go hand in hand with
smart public health measures
here in the uk we still face a risk of
another surge of infections if we're not
very careful about how we open up yeah i
wanted to ask about that because i know
a lot of mps here
have said you know that we need to be
driven by the data and not by the dates
on all of this i mean reiterating what
the pm said
in effect but they're saying the data is
so good at the moment we can accelerate
the the easing of restrictions we are
saying the lesson from chile is
no we can't that's right we have to be
very careful
we often hear about things like a herd
immunity threshold the reality is for
vaccines to sort of tamp down a pandemic
it depends a lot how many cases you have
and so the vaccines are much more
effective at protecting us
when case rates are very low as they are
now
versus when they're very high and so
that's a really important
thing if you look back to just two weeks
ago the chief medical officer
told us in no uncertain terms there will
be
another surge of infections sometime in
july and august
all of the sage modeling predicts this
the question is just how big
and exactly when it will happen so as we
continue to open up that will happen
we also have to remember that our
vaccination campaign here in the uk
has really slowed down quite
significantly the last couple of weeks
because of a shortage of supply
and so i think they're going to be some
really difficult decisions that need to
be made about whether
that slowing rate of vaccination means
we need to think about that timeline for
reopening
in terms of chile are we seeing the
situation that work
there might be a surge in cases but
obviously with with a lot of people
vaccinated
is that then translating into a surge in
serious
cases and an increase in deaths
it's a little bit early but we certainly
are seeing a significant rise in the
number of hospitalizations and um uh and
they've increased the number of icu beds
and those are getting overwhelmed
um so as we've always seen it's cases
first then hospitalizations then deaths
that are rising
that certainly does appear to be the
case now there is a shifting
younger in the demographics of new cases
because like everywhere chile was mostly
vaccinating older adults first
but when you see a surge to this level
eventually you're going to end up with
people in the hospital and you're going
to end up with an increase in deaths
okay dr drobatch and dr babu good to
talk to you both this morning thank you
how's that for a lesson for us all as we
celebrate you know the easing of
lockdown restrictions
if we aren't careful we could end up
like chilly and that's what the experts
are saying so it's
it's really worth bearing in mind at the
moment now the pandemic we know has put
a dent in efforts to cut
back on plastic pollution it's thought
that in the last 12 months
almost 20 billion disposable masks have
been used in the uk
alone now one company is working to turn
discarded ppe into new products
including school
chairs and tool boxes dan whitehead
reports
the pandemic and plastic have gone hand
in hand
millions of single-use face masks gowns
and curtains
have been vital to the fight against
covid but it's created
thousands of tons of waste one company
in cardiff thinks
it has the solution six nhs hospitals
have already taken delivery of their
specialist
machines that convert used ppe
into reusable plastic we have
a number of trusts now using our
machines and
specifically to take out the plastics
and also the face mask which has become
a huge problem in the current pandemic
you take royal cornwall for instance
they're using 10 000 masks a day
instead of being incinerated or going to
landfill
thermal heating is used to melt down the
ppe
we've got around 3 000 faulty single-use
face masks here what happens is they go
inside the machine at the hospital for
around an hour what comes out is this 20
kilogram block of plastic
it's being reused already to make things
like tool boxes
and new school chairs the aim to go full
circle on ppe waste
at the start of the pandemic the world
health organization called on
governments and manufacturers to
increase
single-use ppe production by 40
in china output of masks soared to 116
million
per day in february last year around 12
times the usual amount one study
suggests that in the last 12 months
19.2 billion single-use face masks
have been used in the uk alone weighing
around
55 000 tons to put that into context the
weight of face masks used in the uk
in the last year is equivalent to around
37
000 cars a huge amount
but still a tiny proportion of the 220
million tons of waste
the uk produces every year there has
been
an increase in ppe that we're all well
aware about
but um the system the waste management
system
has coped it's very resilient system
uh we are not talking about huge amount
of volumes of material compared to the
overall amount that we're handling
for the uk as a whole in any given year
there is little sign of ppe demand
falling being able to turn this coved
waste
into something new could be the
long-term solution
dan white is sky news in cardiff
i didn't catch up with plenty of stories
like these on the daily climate show
here on sky news every weekday at half
six
and half nine
still to come on breakfast i'm going to
be talking to a
seven-year-old boy who's on a mission to
help those in poverty
from the 1st of november 1939
until the end of the war i was living on
the nazi
occupation and i went through all the
things that
that followed which was ghetto um
concentrate well first labor comes and
concentration comes and i ended up in
bergen-belsen
when i was liberated by the british
army it gets worse as time goes on and
what one things back
and it's although it's also becoming
sort of
unbelievable i thought how could all
that happen
but nevertheless it's still very painful
it never really goes away it is very
important that people
are aware and that they know that
they're educated about
what can happen when a civilization
breaks down
when their spot rules when there is
prejudice and discrimination
it all starts very slowly i mean it was
a long process of
over five and a half years but
um i don't know it's difficult to read
to sort of accept that the whole world
stood by and um
well nothing happens for five and a half
years
looking back on it it it it
so it is very horrific but
i i won't say i obviously believe it
i've been through it
and that's why i'm talking and i think
it's important for people to know
what happened and and and not to be
bystanders and
and to take action and to really
care about what's going going on in the
world
and much as we do very often nothing
you know no help comes well no help came
to us for five and a half years
but i know it was a terrible war it was
a war
where so much happened there's so much
to learn about
it and hopefully that you know it could
be avoided with enough education and
people taking action
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast but wherever you are welcome to
safety ridge what's the day podcast for
the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
from sky news sky news podcasts
listen and subscribe for free did you
know that
air pollution isn't just bad for the
environment it's bad for our health too
[Music]
the weather's looking very quiet over
the next few days mostly fine by day but
still frosty by night
and certainly for today we'll see cloud
building up over some western areas
and this will bring a scattering of
showers temperatures
up to around 12 degrees celsius for many
but
perhaps 13 or 14 for some in terms of
air pollution the levels are likely to
be low and indeed they stay low
in the immediate forecast period but
could rise to moderate in the west
as we get to the weekend the air quality
report
sponsored by philips air purifiers
now at the start of lockdown henry
sinclair began collecting
food in a box outside his home for
people who live in poverty and needed
extra food it was a huge success and a
year on the donation box
is still overflowing now even more
remarkably when
he came up with the idea henry was six
now he's a grand old age of seven and
he's been recognized for his efforts
with a special award well henry and his
mum
katie join us now really good to see you
both look
how did you come up with this idea henry
um because in lockdown
i started to do this so people didn't go
hungry because they couldn't go to the
shops
so i asked pettington to drop food off
on their daily walks
are you do you think you're quite a
lucky boy you've got a
enough to eat at home
yes
mom in all of this you i i'd love to
know what your your first thought was
when this was suggested to you
well initially it was just a question
and
henry was something so far you know
regular regular day
you know as we were trying to process
the start of lockdown last year and
he just said mum what happens now i
can't go to the supermarket
and i can't donate in their drop boxes
at the soup
you know the supermarket so it's like
okay
let's have a think let's see what we
could do and and um
came up with putting the box outside the
house and just asking our local village
to um on their daily walks wasn't it and
to to drop a can off and and we said
that we could help that way
and the the overwhelming support from
the village has been incredible within
within like the first 24 hours the box
was overflowing and
and it still does to this day so um it's
pretty incredible really
were you surprised henry when you the
first day when you saw the box was full
yes i was very surprised because
it was just my first time and the box
was overflowing what do you think then
henry
of of the people in your village who who
walk past your house every day and pop
something in the box for other people
um well it's very good because
then we can go and drop it off for the
one can base for them to give
to people who don't have much food
tell you what mom you've brought up a
young boy here with the right attitude
haven't you you must be very proud of
him
oh just listen to him speak there you
know he's so passionate
and this has been we are we are
incredibly proud of henry because it's
not sure
this is something that he feels really
passionate about and
you know every day and he'll he'll pop
out down
down to the box check the boxes form so
you know go on go and sort it out and
off he goes
he he puts on his gloves and sorts it
all out and
he was a little bit sad when we went
back to school because he couldn't do
the one
can drop and so we couldn't take it to
one can because he's at school in those
uh those hours um but he he looks
forward to the holidays when we can we
can do it together again
yeah but now the one can trust
foundation
um has decided that you're a you're a
street hero
henry how does it feel to be a hero
um it's good
i'm a good hero aren't you not all
heroes have capes though do they
you're very you're a very modest hero
very modest hero
but it it just goes to show doesn't it
casey that you know
if people can donate the smallest
amounts a single can
it can so quickly add up absolutely
absolutely every week so as you said
we've been doing this a year so
so we're celebrating 52 drops we do it
every week
and what's incredible is that people and
have become really thoughtful in their
donations as well and
you know opening up and making sure that
we're getting things of dietary
requirements you know gluten-free stuff
dairy-free stuff so um so everyone
has has something to to receive that you
know that do have dietary needs
and so yeah it's incredible and it does
add up
every can counts it's it's quite
something as well i mean i don't know
how big your village is
but for the people there i mean it's
you're a sort of
village of heroes aren't you absolutely
aren't we yeah henry will quite often
stand on the doorstep and if he sees
someone dropping off he'll shout out
thank you
um he is you you're grateful we're all
grateful one can grateful you're
grateful
keeps you busy doesn't it yeah
so how long are you going to keep this
going do you think is this is this
something you
that's gonna happen every week from here
on in
um well i'm only gonna do it until one
can
um tell me to stop doing it
so basically as long as they need me
i'm sure that could be a very long time
look really good he's got one oh god
he's got one aspiration
following on from being a street hero is
that
for insurance purposes he can't join
them in the warehouse
but when he's eight he's allowed to go
in aren't you
yes ah well not long to wait for that
only another 12 months and you'll be in
there being able to have a look round
really good to see you both this morning
and well done henry
i think you you show us all what we need
to be doing you're an inspiration
definitely you're on your own well it is
early
i easy it does go to show that we should
all
sort of make the effort and a little bit
can really make a big difference
anyway let's see what the weather's
going to do for you today morning joe
you
i've heard you say this morning it's
quiet weather-wise
it is it's very quiet high pressure in
control so
much calmer much more settled than it
has been what i can't promise at the
moment
uh are temperatures recovering too much
they're pretty much back to what they
should be for the time of year during
the day
but overnight we're still seeing frosts
so be warned let's take a look at the
details
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airway
hello there good morning to you well
really uh say high pressure in control
for most it's going to be calm it's
going to be settled we'll see some
sunshine
also a scattering of showers these
mostly in the west and top temperatures
of around 12 or 13 degrees celsius
that's 55 degrees fahrenheit
the weather sponsored by qatar airways